on the hill for the marlins it is jesus
luzardo six starts with the marlins he
was able to shave two runs off the era
with that start against cincinnati last
weekend galvez
galvez playing third base now was
originally listed as the shortstop but
uh starling marty is a important guy to
get for them and that was a big move for
them that ball is hit well out to left
center field brinson's on the run to the
wall it's gone a home run for freddie
galvez
right out of the gate he gives the phils
a one-nothing lead it's his first home
run since coming back it's his tenth
overall and the phil's once again jump
out early
kyle gibson who rocks and fires his
first pitch and jazz lines one to right
harper not gonna get there and one hops
up and over the wall and a first pitch
double for jazz chisholm junior zu
sanchez to the plate a couple of runners
on and one out
two two to sanchez he's driven a long
way deep to right field back goes harper
he's at the wall goodbye into the
bullpen a three-run homer for jesus
sanchez and the marlins turn this game
around on one big swing it's 3-1 in the
bottom of the first
now one and a bat from sanchez he saw
just about the entire arsenal
comes up with another big swing
matt vearling
0-2 pitch and it's grounded just fair
over the first base bag it goes down the
right field line all the way to the
corner touch on his way towards third
dusty waffen waving him around verling
heading for third the relay will be cut
off there's no throw to the bases but
cutchen scores and it's an rbi triple
for matt vearling his first run batted
in in the big leagues
tell you what
aguilar who's on the back because
there's a runner there takes one step
off the back and might have slipped just
a little bit
trying to go back towards the line but
as you said that was hit so hard 105 off
the bat again
that uh
he's able to sneak it by him even though
he's only one step off the back
one out runner from philadelphia here in
the top of the third inning base runner
on for bryce harper
aguilar
to miggy
and
got him
well harper's grounded into two double
plays tonight
and you know they've got a great
rotation so it makes it difficult
grounded to third galveston second for
one segoric hesitates for a moment and
still fires to first in time
as jt leads off the fourth the phillies
trail it by one
hot shot off the leg of panic at third
and jt is aboard with the lead off
single
ground ball aguilar's got it and we'll
get back to the bag
nicely done by luzardo a couple of runs
in four innings of
[Music]
work 1-1 pitch and a swing of the
comebacker gibson's got it fires to
segura now they're trying to get sanchez
in a rundown they do he flips to galvez
chasing him back towards second now the
tag by didi gregorius
and out at second base
is sanchez who actually is ruled out of
the baseline
this is a great play by gibson and those
are the things that are that you don't
see in the box score necessarily gibson
can do a lot of things
princeton goes
pitches low throw to second base picked
on one hop by gregorius and what a tag
[Applause]
second base runner that marshad has
thrown out this year
here comes freddie galvez who
we just mentioned led off the game of
the home run it was the ninth
lead off home run of the season
that one's whacked out to right field
that's going to get past
sanchez it's going to go to the corner
and freddie's going to get to second
base
it's a two-out double
the off-speed pitches into right middle
hold up for sanchez
it's a good five innings against it
but he walks mccutchen
and that will bring up virling with two
away
with regard to some of these guys
and a line drive out to left field
that's going to be in for another base
hit
it's just inside the line mccutchen's
around third heading for home
the throw in won't be there in time it's
another rbi extra base hit for beerling
and the phillies have tied this game up
at three he hits it off the end of the
bat but he places it right down the line
and
then you see mccutchen going off to the
races again
jazz who doubled and scored in the first
inning
and rips this one a fair ball this one's
going to go to the wall jazz is going to
have another extra base hit
he's on his way to second and he's still
going through from segura gets away from
galves
and jazz into third
now that go ahead run is it third the
phillies bring the infield in
it's owen one on rojas
and that gets through segura into right
field
jazz will come in to score and the
marlins take a 4-3 lead
[Applause]
and this was just a fastball away
and mickey just
did exactly what you're supposed to do
you go with it and you smoke it
especially with the infield in
here's al farro
and at base it into left field in comes
rojos
everybody moves station to station on
the rbi single from jorge alfaro
ground ball basin up the middle for joe
panic in comes aguilar they will hold
sanchez
and again everybody moves up 90 feet joe
panic with the rbi now 6-3
payoff pitch
is high for ball four
that is another run for the marlins rbi
for de la cruz as sanchez comes in to
score
faces loaded one down takes in the dirt
rolls away from marshawn toward the
first base dugout here comes alfaro
he'll score on the wild pitch and the
morals have scored five in the inning
it's eight to three rojas batting for
the second time this inning in an rbi
single
a 2-2 pitch coming
and that's up the middle of base
basement
here comes panic here comes de la cruz
he'll score rojas brings home two more
just quality and bad after quality at
bat rojas following suit going right
back through the middle
watch out jd hammer